[Music]
I'm here with Hugh Jackman the star of
The Wolverine hi Cara hi how are you
thanks so much for being here I'm like
the Wonder Woman yes that your alter-ego
today it is always a day oh they told me
I wasn't allowed to wear my hood but are
you gonna do it oh yes so I like your
alter ego yeah and you know what's funny
is that I was watching a 60 Minutes
interview with you and you were talking
about playing Jean Valjean and how it
was kind of a role of a lifetime and how
your entire acting career kind of built
up to that but that Wolverine is really
you but that's a new character well you
know maybe they cut it out but certainly
I will never be able to ex actually
discuss roles of my lifetime without
mentioning this guy because it's been 13
years now and I'm about I'm playing it
now for the seventh time which still
amazes me even for those words to come
out of my mouth I think for any actor
you're amazed to ever get hired again
for anything let alone the same part
seven times you know so and I love the
care I'm probably enjoying it more now
than ever Keira really and I don't think
that anybody can think of you without
thinking of Wolverine or think of
Wolverine without thinking of you it's
so symbolic well that's what I want my
kids to think yeah yeah well as soon as
they then give me any lip trust me this
guy comes out well that's what I was
wondering is that when you spend so much
of your life playing the same role in
developing that character I'm wondering
if it's if there's a clear distinction
or if it starts to become blurry sort of
where he stops and everything no I think
there's a very clear distinction and in
fact probably a much happier nicer calm
a person for playing him for six months
have read two or three years I get to
expel all my anger all the rage that all
comes out on a daily basis yeah although
the other day my daughter did say oh and
I'm shooting x-men Days of Future past
right now and I was going up back for
four days shooting and she's not dead
you're gonna leave I said I'm sorry she
goes I know that makes me really kind of
sad and happy and I'm happy she goes
well whenever you're playing Wolverine
you are a lot stricter than you normally
are I was like I think you guys so maybe
it is but maybe the lines are blurring
so yeah do you ever forget that you
don't actually have claws I never forget
because I do have them after that my do
after the second movie was ridiculous
replacing them all the time that I just
had them surgically put in you mention
the airports and this v9o know that
actually the problem was as an actor
every job you do you gotta punch someone
whether it's on stage and I so you're so
used to pulling a punch right stop in
there that when I first started yeah it
was I actually had to really practice
imagining that I had to stop here
instead of stopping here I stabbed a
number of people I should know their
names because I feel you should probably
know the names of people you stab but
anyway a number of people I have stabbed
including myself I don't want yeah I
mean equal-opportunity stabbing suddenly
having a body part that's a weapon yes I
mean how sharp are they really well in
the first movie that were literally not
seriously they were so sharp
every time I'm clumsy too I have long
arms and long and they look you know I'm
like the robot in you know the Robinsons
you know that guy Danger Danger
so as I was swinging that kept coming to
my thigh I got myself in the forehead
and they were so sharp that now they've
made them like PVC very I'm still sharp
enough to have some ones I have but not
as dangerous as they used to be yeah
when you come to comic-con I mean this
must be kind of the epitome of fandom
for you right this is where all of the
biggest Wolverine fans come every year
how many times have you been to
comic-con now how many of four times
I've only been here twice with this
character and there is nothing quite
like it in fact it's always a little
it's difficult for the people who bring
me say a say I came for Van Helsing in
universe though I could see they were
like every question I got was about
Wolverine the entire front when we were
presenting van Helsing there were like
12 like Wolverines with a shirts off
Jack just yelling to the whole thing it
was kind of like there's really no point
me coming here unless it's with
Wolverine and it's it's a great
opportunity for me because I owe my
career to this character and to the fans
who've made it possible and I get one
shot every three or four years to say
thank you to them and not only that
that creators Len Wein Chris Claremont
all these guys are here and it's Stan
Lee and it's it's a great opportunity
for me to say thank you to them I want
to know about this new film about the
Wolverine so this is focusing just on
that character you're in Japan and it
seems kind of dark it's a long darker I
mean if there's ever a tone of a movie
that should fit the character a woman
it's dark I mean really I think what
Nolan did with Batman was fantastic and
paved the way and I think we had an
opportunity to this movie and for
whatever is a better worse I think the
first Wolverine movie ended up feeling
like another x-men movie we had a bunch
of you know different mutants and in
this it's not that it's not wall-to-wall
mutants it's not wall-to-wall CGI it's
actually you know even as spectacular as
the action scenes are that they're in a
way quite human and quite visceral and
real and that's I think the time we
needed for this character Ted of a
character study of Wolverine absolutely
because he is I'm biased one of the more
interesting of the comic book heroes
even in his DNA I mean when he was
created there went a lot of anti heroes
he may have been the first you know and
I think he's very real defining
qualities of human quality it's that the
rage that's the reason you don't want to
piss him off and it's not I mean look
he's got claws again himself he can't
fly can jump buildings he can doesn't
have lasers coming out of his eyes and
so if you're gonna make a movie called
the Wolverine you have to get inside
what makes him tick and it's that
berserker rage and all the pain and crap
that kind of makes that possible
so when you're here at Comic Con yeah
obviously you're doing panels you're
doing signings you have all of the the
fanfare around it you can't just walk
the floor it's it's so funny you mention
that because honestly already today I
have seen three Logan look-alikes that
look more like me than me and I'm this
guy that's me
yeah that's me I honestly think if I
walked out there through Hall age as
Wolverine people are going yeah and I'll
bet these all right mm a little too tall
there apart from that I think that's the
way I should get about you have to try
that I think I really should I'm gonna
do it one you're gonna come to full
thing like that and what people go yeah
whatever
so I have to ask if you hugh jackman you
the man have any superpower yeah
like for real a superpower what would it
be
teleporting yeah but that I mean I love
travelling a family all over the world
my kids are back in LA I'm in San Diego
if I could go and swim in Bondi Beach in
Sydney every morning and then I could
pop into work wherever I am around the
world that by far would be the best
thing so super power of convenience
right totally
yeah convenience and avoiding you know
security at airports it's pretty much
what it's about
well yeah because I mean they're just
gonna give you trouble for those Clause
was a great record yeah pull back a job
I know I love that see that is why you
are one woman no problem I'm Hugh
Jackman we're at Comic Con this is Keira
aka Wonder Woman and you are with wired
[Music]